dr marty mccary now fox news contributor
and professor at the john hopkins
university school of
public health dr mccary thanks for
joining me my first question for you
is it you know when we point to the
science of this
how common is it for people working in a
laboratory like that and wuhan
to get so sick that they need to be
hospitalized that they
were working on something that did that
to them potentially how common is that
well look at lab accidents are very
common and
this information that three lab workers
were seen and evaluated and hospitalized
is enough circumstantial evidence now
that it's no longer a lab hypothesis
it is the default conclusion and we can
call for more investigations all we want
but we're not going to get it we're not
going to get witness protection
for those key sources we're not going to
get the original samples they've
probably been destroyed we probably have
all the info we need right now
well we'd have to also locate all of
those scientists and and china from
everything i'm reading is still not
playing ball what role do you suspect
that the world health organization could
have played in all of this
whether they knew that they were playing
that role or not
you know i don't even think they could
have they led a sham investigation they
put the funder of the lab
peter dazzak on the investigation
committee which is a complete conflict
of interest but look even if they did
that investigation properly
i think the evidence has been destroyed
and we're not going to see the witness
protection needed so
i think that enough circumstantial
evidence is there now that there's a
conclusion that can be made i've
certainly made a conclusion knowing how
common lab accidents are it's i think
it's no longer a lab hypothesis
i think that's exactly what happened so
dr mccary when you look at this last
question on this we'll move to the next
after this but
when when you look at this what's
important that we know
after all this time i mean is it how
much could it have saved us if we had
known what we know even now
circumstantially
look if we knew the origin i don't think
it would have changed anything with this
particular outbreak the initial doctors
sounded the alarm
three of them were detained by the
police at least one of them was forced
to sign the statement
that's public information so i don't
think it would have changed anything
in terms of future pandemics we should
not be characterizing
viruses that live in the zoonotic
kingdom there's a million viruses in the
world
why are we funding research to bring
them into the lab and characterize them
that doesn't make sense
yeah i just was wondering if the timing
i mean november was so
far away from where we saw our first
suspected uh cases which were
in 2020 the beginning of 2020 would that
lead time have helped us at all we'll
never know
all right kentucky senator rand paul who
tested positive for covid19 last year
now says he will not get a covid vaccine
shot until he sees evidence that's more
effective than natural immunity let's
watch
i already had it i mean should they
force people to get vaccinated that
already had covid and survived
they would first have to prove that the
vaccine is better than being infected i
think that
we should have a choice whether we take
a vaccine or not because
frankly all the studies show that i have
just as good of immunity
as the people who've been vaccinated
dr mccarry your response to that
well he's right the studies do show
there and there's actually more evidence
on natural immunity than there is on
vaccinated immunity because natural
immunity has been around a lot longer
and it's effective it works we don't see
reinfections at any appreciable degree
and his scientific logic is rational
he's a doctor and he's actually a smart
doctor i've talked to him
that makes sense why do we always
distinguish
vaccinated and unvaccinated as if
natural immunity
it does not exist that is ultimately i
think one of the great failures of our
medical leadership
is ignoring natural immunity which
changes everything
you know i'm wondering then how do
people get it twice
well look we know breakthrough
infections happen after vaccinated
immunity
they're rare and they're mild that's the
same with natural immunity in the giant
study in denmark it was six tenths of
one percent and presumably most of those
cases are mild
just because somebody tests positive
does not mean we've got a health problem
the pcr test
can detect as few as 10 molecules of
viral particles in your nose
that doesn't mean you have the infection
it may mean your immune system worked to
fend off the infection
yeah maybe trying to do some things we
didn't though too because remember they
started testing people
on the opposite ends not their nose but
but uh
their bums if you will just to be
delicate because it's 11 a.m eastern
dr fauci and cdc head director wolinski
say
they understand why people are afraid to
remove their masks
you can understand that when people have
been following
a certain trend for a considerable
period of time that it may take time for
them to adjust
not everybody is going to feel like it's
time to rip off their masks for 16
months we've been saying that it's
important to wear these masks to protect
yourselves and now what we're saying is
um it's going to be hard to get back to
um to you know life as we knew it
without these masks
you know i'm old enough to remember
because it's only been a few months
uh when dr fauci said on 60 minutes
overtime that's the online version of 60
minutes
you watch it a little bit when the
show's over and sometimes you get little
drips like
well masks aren't the really end-all
be-all i mean i remember when he was not
really encouraging people
to to wear masks maybe the mixed
messaging played a role
in all of this people's perception about
whether or not they should take them off
or keep them on
look when many of us had a public
argument with dr fauci at the beginning
of the pandemic he just thought this was
going to peter out like
sars did back in the day he was around
for sars and he just thought it was
going to poop out in china
and it didn't and so look that was a
mistake but
where we are now is the cdc dropped this
without any warning
or notice they give us notice for school
guidance for camp guidance for
everything else for the vaccine
allocation guidance
but this they just dropped on folks and
now they're sort of backpedaling and
saying well you know it's reasonable
that
may want to you may want to continue to
wear masks they ignored natural immunity
to your earlier point
harris and as a result they
miscalculated the high degree of
population immunity out there today
and when you've got 80 to 85 percent of
adults immune which is exactly where we
are today in the united states
because roughly half of unvaccinated
people have natural immunity
you're going to see significant slowing
they were caught off guard and they
released this
very quickly because of public demand
dr mccary always a pleasure to have you
and your expertise on the show
johns hopkins university is lucky to
have you thank you